all right guys
bang bang i've got a very special guest
for you today
mr rick edelman he is uh the number one
financial advisor in the world
uh multiple years i would rattle off all
the years but there's been so many of
them that
uh i can't remember them all so thank
you so much for doing this sir
oh it's great to be with you paul thanks
so much for having me for sure
um you've spent a long time and been
very very successful as a financial
advisor walk us through
kind of your story in terms of how did
you eventually get into the business and
then how did you grow
you know such an amazing practice and
client base
well my wife and i were really married
and like you know all newlyweds we
wanted to buy a house
and realize we didn't know really
anything about that so we went to a
financial planner for help and advice
and he ended up telling us to commit a
felony
he told us to lie on our mortgage
application to qualify for the loan
and we were aghast we were infuriated
that
he would tell us to do this and it made
us realize
you know getting good effective advice
not so easy
uh and you know what we're gonna learn
how to do this on our own and then we're
going to teach others what we've learned
and that was the basis for forming our
practice we were in our 20s
in a community where we didn't grow up
didn't go to college had no family and
so we were all by ourselves
and started out to basically right the
wrong
and to provide an oasis a safe haven for
consumers who don't have millions of
dollars don't
have access to the fabulous levels of
advice on wall street no banks of
lawyers and accountants to assist
but folks who are just desperately
trying to do the right thing get their
kids through college and
save for their retirement care for
elderly parents
and so that was the basis of our firm
when we started it back in 1986
35 years ago was to provide financial
education to help people
understand how money works and how to
make it work for them
and the message got around we began
doing
college planning seminars for elementary
school pta groups young parents with
young kids
who don't know anything about this stuff
it was back in the 80s nobody ever heard
of financial planning
and so most folks back then never owned
a mutual fund
uh and so word spread and and i was
invited onto the radio and and
later television and uh so today
you know i'm the longest running
national radio talk show
on personal finance i've written 10
books i'm the best-selling
author of all financial advisors in
history we've got about a million copies
of my books in print collectively
published in seven languages i'm a
number one new york times bestselling
author
i've been hosting tv shows for decades
most recently a series of specials for
public television
and people like the the message that we
deliver this
educational unbiased objective
information
in an entertaining and fun way because
let's face it it's a boring subject
uh and as a result of all that we've now
become the largest
investment advisory firm in the nation
where the largest independent ra in the
country serving 1.2 million
households and managing about 230
billion dollars of assets
uh and edelman financial engines is also
now also the largest
uh provider provider of advice to 401k
plans in the country about 140 of the
fortune 500 are our clients
from boeing ford uh landa lakes and
delta and so on and so it's been very
gratifying
to be able to help so many uh people
across the country
yeah it's an amazing story just in terms
of almost
accidentally starting a business right
and kind of seeing a problem going and
solving it and then scaling it
um just before we get into some of the
things that we're going to talk about
around financial assets markets and
crypto assets
as an entrepreneur i think a lot of
people in financial services don't think
of themselves that way
but you obviously have built a business
and been an entrepreneur what's like the
one lesson that you wish that you could
have told yourself when you first
started
uh this journey and you know before you
had 200 plus billion dollars in assets
like is there one lesson that would have
been
incredibly valuable for you we learned a
lot
over the years a lot of it was
confirmatory the benefit i had is that i
grew up in an entrepreneurial household
my mom and dad
ran a small business and so sitting
around the kitchen table every night at
dinner and listening to them talk
shop was very natural for me to grow up
starting a business because i watched my
parents do it
and so there weren't terribly many
surprises a lot of it was confirmed
everything takes twice as long and costs
twice as much for example
uh and cash flow is king
we all know that lack of cash flow is
what wipes out most small businesses and
so
gina and i kept our expenses
extraordinarily low we moved into a
one-bedroom
basement apartment we sold all of our
furniture everything we owned to provide
as much cash as we could to the business
my very first office space i had someone
who allowed me to go into their office
and i'm not kidding they literally
gave me a window sill so my very first
office was a stool
along a window and on that windowsill i
had a
telephone and that was it so you you do
whatever it takes to
get by minimizing expenses to devote
all of your energy and attention to the
clients you're trying to serve
and if you stay focused on those clients
do whatever it takes to help them
you'll it'll be okay for you too so you
know too often people are wondering
what's in it for me
that that is a deadly attitude just take
care of the folks you're trying to help
the rest will take care of itself
yeah i think that's a great piece of a
piece of advice not only for
entrepreneurs but anyone who's trying to
build value
you've been doing this for a long time
and because you've had a lot of success
that allows you to do it for such a long
period of time
you've probably seen almost everything
and for my friends who are financial
advisors i've heard some pretty crazy
stories
uh in the good times last year was one
of those times that weren't so great in
terms of a lot of volatility in
asset prices there was a lot of
uncertainty a lot of
kind of chaos what were some of the
things that clients were coming to you
and your colleagues
either with concerns or kind of some of
the
crazier stories that you guys are
hearing in terms of
the small business owners those that are
self-employed or even just
you know kind of your average client
well we all know that last year was
unprecedented uh you know we all
most of us remember 911 and we
recall the 2008 credit crisis and many
of us go back all the way to the crash
of 87
and remember those tumultuous times the
oil embargo with the 70s the dot-com
bubble bursting in 2000 and yet
last year 2020 was unprecedented because
it was a health
crisis in addition to a financial crisis
and the
unpredictability of the pandemic the
unexpected behavior of the stock market
is really one for the record books and
there are going to be a lot of phds
produced with dissertations on all of it
and it was and making it even more
horrific and complicated was the
presidential election and its outcome
resulting in the horrific violence uh on
the day that the electoral college uh
was ratified by the
congress and as we record this you know
we are yet waiting for the inauguration
and events
yet to unfold so there's a lot of
anxiety and
a lot of fear and confusion as to what
does all this mean
where is it going to lead what's the
outcome going to be
and while financial advisors like me
admonish our clients remind our clients
hand hold our clients to
stay focused on the long term look out
10 years from now
20 years from now that's hard to do when
the headlines when the videos that
you're seeing on the evening news
are so shocking and so polarizing
it's hard to do that and so what we're
finding is that some folks
are allowing their political views
to color their financial decisions
those who are very very angry at
president trump's defeat uh are
therefore becoming very very pessimistic
and selling their securities because
they think the worst
those who are elated at joe biden's
election
are euphoric and optimistic and they're
increasing their
stock allocation and both of those camps
are wrong
in one camp you're getting too risky
with too much stock the other one you're
getting too conservative and too low in
return with too little
stock both are going to lament it as
they reach retirement
so our focus has been to help people
separate their political views their
social attitudes from their investment
strategy
because when you mix the two you're
normally doing it for the wrong reasons
at the wrong times then the outcome will
not be what you wanted
it's so funny because basically what
you're describing is not only are you a
financial advisor but
in some way you are a therapist a
psychologist
and many other uh things that don't kind
of come with the job description correct
well yeah we've always felt that way i
mean we're not professional
social workers or psychologists and we
have a lot of clients who are and
they cringe whenever we move on to their
turf because we don't have their
experience
expertise or degrees but you're right
we are often engaging in the human
emotions side of things
what the joke that i've often made over
the years is that managing money is easy
managing clients is hard
think that's a great way to look at it
so as you've been um
you know kind of shepherding literally
over a million clients over the years
uh one of the things that's come up is
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and
you know my understanding from uh kind
of the approach that you've taken is
you've actually been very
forward-looking
um and somewhat embracing of innovation
and saying look this is an interesting
asset class maybe walk us through just
how did you come across
bitcoin and crypto and blockchain
technology and
what has your journey been with this
asset class
yeah i've always been a planner you know
meaning look to the future where are we
going
how are we going to get there and i'm
well known in the financial planning
community for being innovative
and being a thought leader uh i am
pretty routinely
named on all of the lists of the most
influential
thought leaders in our field because i'm
always challenging the status quo
why are we giving that particular kind
of advice and why aren't we doing this
instead and so on
and i've got a long record over the past
three decades of innovations in our
field i have two patents for example for
financial product innovation
and i uh invented the uh first
exponential technologies etf which was
launched by i shares
about five six years ago and
as part of that i try to spend time with
futurist technologists uh scientists
experts
in a variety of technology fields and
and several years ago oh maybe
gosh it's almost a decade now i had the
opportunity to interview ray kurzweil
uh he i interviewed him from my tv show
on public television and ray is in the
faculty of harvard he's now director of
engineering at google
and he is considered by many that thomas
edison of our age the albert einstein of
our age one of the
smartest men on the planet uh he has
700 patents i think uh and ray is the
co-founder of singularity university
along with peter diamandis
peter's the guy responsible for the
first privately funded space flight
uh uh ever made and
ray encouraged me to go to singularity
and to attend the
executive program which i did in late
2012.
i uh then became an investor in
singularity university and
a lecturer there as well and at
singularity i learned all about these
exponential technologies ai robotics
nanotech biotech bioinformatics 3d
printing
big data fintech edtech and of course
blockchain and bitcoin this was 2012
and i'd never heard of bitcoin before
and i was very curious
trying to understand what is this uh and
getting my arms around it so i spent
much of 2013 trying to
figure all that out began investing in
early 2014
so i was one of the relatively early
adopters to bitcoin
uh first as an academic exercise but
later beginning to realize there's a
there
there uh and what i quickly learned were
two things
number one um most financial advisors
are oblivious
to the blockchain and digital assets
which i think is a dis
advantage for themselves and their
clients and second
uh the crypto community is inventing
some
pretty nifty whiz-bang products and
services
now the blockchain is going to prove to
be
one of the most powerful innovative
technologies
i believe since the internet itself was
invented
and we're only just now beginning to see
its impact
and it's going to have transformative
effects on
commerce on a global scale in all
industries
virtually every major bank in the world
is developing blockchain technology
governments around the world are all
experimenting with digital
coins many have already begun to roll
them out china sweden and the bahamas
for example with many others along the
way the fed
is doing a lot of research and so my
exposed all of this led me to ask a
simple question of all these experts i
was talking to
what does it mean for personal finance
and they couldn't really answer that
question they were showing me the
whiz-bang techno
stuff they were building self-driving
cars for example and nanotech
robots that will be traveling through
your bloodstream and things like that
but they couldn't explain the impact on
personal finance and that was my
research for much of the last decade
and i finally figured it out and it
culminated in my publication of my most
recent book the truth about your future
which is a deep dive into exponential
technologies what they are how they work
and what does it mean for your personal
finances
investments taxes mortgages insurance
career and college homeownership even
marriage and estate planning and that
book was
debuted on the new york times business
bestseller list
and made me realize that financial
advisors need to get on
with the program they need to understand
all of this so that the advice they're
giving their clients
is advice for the 21st century not
advice rooted in the 20th
um a very uh
famous quote is that companies that were
built for success in the 20th century
will fail in the 21st and we're already
seeing that if you look at the biggest
companies in america they didn't exist
in the 20th century
you know you're looking at companies
like twitter and google and amazon
compared to for example kodak which
filed bankruptcy uh the very year that
instagram
uh was sold for a billion dollars and so
we have to understand these new
exponential technologies and bitcoin is
one of the most tangible
ways that ordinary investors can engage
in these
from an investment perspective and so i
created readac
the riaa digital assets council as a
way to provide education and knowledge
for the financial advisory community to
help them understand
these technologies to determine whether
or not they should
incorporate them into their clients
portfolios and if so how to go about
doing that
and how to bridge the crypto community
to the advisory community
because it's the crypto community that's
making all these nifty wiz-bang products
and services but it's the advisory
community that are the gatekeepers
to investors and their assets so redec
is the bridge to bring the two of them
together
and we've launched a certification
program to help advisors
get the knowledge they need and then to
be able to demonstrate that they've
become experts
to their clients by holding the
certificate in blockchain and digital
assets
so it's been very very exciting uh as
we've been developing all of this for
financial advisors
and so today the financial advisor
community i think that you really
highlighted like
uh they knew nothing along with
everybody else in the world knew nothing
about this technology
uh there's then this eureka moment hey
this is going to be important
then there's this education journey
which you're being a a
huge proponent of and really
facilitating um and then there is kind
of the allocation the client
conversations
um and the execution if you will of the
strategy
help us understand where exactly would
you put most financial advisors today
are we in the
we just had the eureka moment and now
there's education are we
no we've been being educated for the
last two or three years and now we're
close to execution
is there maybe a distribution of those
different um kind of
uh points in the uh in the spectrum how
do you just look at like where are
financial advisors when it comes to
crypto currently
we're still very very early we are in a
slow metamorphosis it is accelerating
but it is still very early
uh up until relatively recently i'd say
within the last year or two
advisors were largely in the camp of um
i don't believe it uh i that this stuff
is either
uh a fad or worse a fraud
uh that bitcoin is nothing different
from beanie babies and tulip bulbs
and if you look merely at the volatility
of bitcoin over its 12-year life
yeah it's easy to look at it as a tulip
bulb
and we've seen a lot of stories of fraud
you know silk road and mount gox and
others
but those go back 10 years ago that's
not the bitcoin world of today
there has been a massive metamorphosis
uh
in the infrastructure in the ecospace
that exists and what people
thought of five or ten years ago which
was probably accurate
with a an attitude that this won't last
it will eventually go to zero it's a fad
it won't
sustain that is shifting and the
attitude is now
morphed among the financial advisors i
talk with
of i thought it was going to go away to
now
it looks like it's going to stay and
since it's going to stay
i probably better figure out what this
is so advisors aren't yet happy about
bitcoin they're not yet
in favor of bitcoin but they do
grudgingly admit
it looks like it's going to be here to
stay so my clients are asking me
increasingly about it
i better learn what it is so i can talk
answer their questions intelligently
you know in the old days of just telling
them stay away it's a it's a fraud
well that answer is not cutting it
anymore uh and they need to be able to
be more
communicative and informative for their
clients and so
advisors i wouldn't yet say are on board
i wouldn't say that advisors are for the
most part enthusiastic or optimistic or
willing participants
i'd say their skepticism remains high
and that's healthy
but they are willing to acknowledge they
need to learn more to either prove or
disprove their skepticism
and i don't care what their conclusion
is if you want to walk away
hating bitcoin fine i don't care but
just make sure you're doing it with an
informed
decision not out of a bias that is
uneducated
and that's my only goal give you the
knowledge the education the information
and then you'll make your own decision
and that'll be the right decision for
you and your clients
i think it's so important in today's
society right of
whether it's politics whether it is
social issues or
it is financial assets kind of this idea
of understanding
all of the information understanding all
of the different perspectives
on an issue before you make your
decision that lesson could
could be used in many many different
facets of our society for sure
so it's good to hear that that's kind of
the approach that you're taking um
what are the obstacles uh in your mind
whether they're market structure issues
or regulatory issues
or maybe just uncertainties that you
think most financial advisors
uh are either hung up on or paying
attention to like are there certain
things where you're saying
hey you know there's this regulatory
issue and when this gets resolved
there will be uh you know 10 of advisors
will then
kind of rush into the industry or is it
harder to
actually identify specific things and
it's more so just to take time and
education
in a generalized manner well there are
several issues and some of them
are related and others are not there
are practice management issues for
example
how do i buy this for my clients i mean
there isn't a bitcoin etf that would
certainly make life simple and easy
wouldn't it
uh that doesn't exist so how
do you know what are the products and
services that exist out there
uh that i can recommend for my clients
so that's one is
how do i do it um related to that is the
regulatory side
how do i comply with my obligations as a
fiduciary as a licensed financial
advisor
regarding my
kyc and aml obligations for example
how do i track the investments that i
provide to my clients how do i integrate
it into my portfolio how do i rebalance
that account how do i bill on it how do
i get paid for doing this
uh by the way um how do i handle the
record keeping the tax reporting so
there are some fundamental practical
aspects of practice management that
advisors are concerned about
they also need to know what are the
products and where do i go to do this
for my client
what are the risks of having the money
lost due to effect or fraud or hacking
or the service provider going out of
business
because they aren't financially stable
you know so where can i custody with
safety
and along the way how do i know that i
have price integrity
and in fact those are the two
fundamental issues remaining with the
sec
and their deliberation of examining
applications for an etf custody how do
we know
the asset will be well cared for safe
and number two
price how do we know that the price is
legitimate that it's
fair that it isn't being manipulated
because it is largely an unregulated
environment
and the industry has to demonstrate to
the sec that both of those issues have
been resolved within the community
i am confident that the sec will grow
comfortable with that
at some point and say okay to a bitcoin
etf
which will unleash a variety of products
in the marketplace and that'll be good
for investors to have something
under the purview of sec regulatory
oversight will be a whole lot better
than the wild west that often exists
but the financial services community is
not waiting for the sec to do that we
already have
a wide variety of products and a number
of very
established exchanges fidelity is
engaged
already with fidelity digital assets you
have companies like kingdom trust a
qualified custodian with 19 billion
dollars in assets
that allows you to buy own uh
and trade bitcoin and other digital
assets even in an ira account
um you have a number of private
placements that will allow you to invest
as little as 25 000
you have to be an accredited investor
for these kinds of products
but you also have securities like gbtc
ethe and bitw
uh the grayscale bitcoin trust and
ethereum trust and the bitwise top 10
crypto index fund
disclosure i'm an investor in bitwise
and
these allow you a more diversified
approach than just buying one coin or
another so there's a wide variety of
opportunities
already in place it's just that advisors
aren't aware of them
and they don't realize that the industry
has grown up a lot in the last five
years
and what advisors think they know about
bitcoin is for the most part
outmoded outdated information that's no
longer valid
and as a result they're doing themselves
a disservice and their clients
by not learning more about what the
opportunities are today
and so you again as i mentioned are very
very forward-thinking
uh you've really embraced this as one of
the potential things that will be
important in the future along with a
bunch of other technologies and
industries
um i know that you've invested i'm not
sure personally or or through
the business into uh bitwise for an
investor there with you
um and there's a couple of other
companies that you've made investments
in
uh what are you doing for clients in
terms of
is this still hey i'm able to learn
i'm meeting people i'm getting educated
i'm educating other financial advisors
and we're waiting for some regulatory
clarity before we really have a clear
plan
uh what to do with client assets um or
are there things that already you're
comfortable with
and clients are asking for and
interested in uh that you're able to
help them put into the portfolio
like how do you think about here's what
we're actually doing today uh for
clients in crypto so at edelman
financial engines uh we have a very
specific methodology of managing money
and we
choose to limit ourselves to 48 products
etfs and mutual funds
and there's a real simple reason for
that the vast majority of our clients
are not accredited investors they're
they're middle class americans
uh hard-working folks who don't have
millions of dollars to invest and
for these folks the approach that we use
for money management is appropriate and
in their best interests and so we are
waiting uh
for an etf to come along um to
provide for our clients and in the
meantime because there is still a little
bit of a wild west environment out there
uh dealing with folks and organizations
that most
people have never really heard of we are
providing a focus of education
so the advice we're giving our clients
is number one don't invest in this space
until you have the knowledge bitcoin and
other digital assets do not behave
like any other financial assets you are
ever familiar with they have nothing in
common with the stock market the bond
market the oil market the real estate
market the gold market
has nothing in common so you need to get
educated first and foremost
that will help you determine if you want
to go beyond that and if you do
which we're not necessarily recommending
limit your investment to just
one percent of assets i'm the guy who
invented the one percent allocation
strategy for bitcoin
and the reason i did that is because
many financial advisors are fearful of
putting clients into a position with
five percent or ten percent of assets
because that's what you would normally
do with a client portfolio if you're not
gonna do five or ten percent then why
are you even bothering it's pointless to
do just one
and that's true for stocks bonds and
real estate and gold but it's not the
case with bitcoin
a one percent allocation can in fact
have a material
impact on the portfolio but if it goes
broke if it blows up on you as it yet
may
the one percent isn't going to destroy
you financially it'll be annoying but
not devastating
so the one percent allocation can
dramatically
lower the risk while materially
increasing the return of a portfolio
thanks to the fact that bitcoin is a
non-correlated asset it's not merely
negatively correlate correlated it is
non-correlated
and if you truly believe in
diversification a non-correlated asset
is exactly what you want
to improve your diversification so
education first
one percent allocation if you're going
to proceed at all
make sure you plan to hold it for a very
long time and i mean years
and finally don't be surprised if you
lose at all
because that is the nature of the
uncertainty of this emerging asset class
so that's the message we're giving our
clients and we're focusing on
educating as we've been doing for our
35-year career helping people understand
how all this stuff works
so they can make informed decisions that
are best for them
yeah it's fantastic to hear you say this
because i think you're spot on
in terms of the non-correlation there's
also this element of
potential asymmetry and so a small
allocation can drive a uh
a pretty material impact and then the
diversification
there really is no other asset that uh
at least currently provides some of
those uh some of those elements all in
one asset
um talk to me in terms of uh when you
look at
crypto and bitcoin uh there's a big
focus on
get off zero get in the game you know
get some exposure if that's what you
want but
also what's happening with the rest of
the portfolio um you know 6040 has
served as the standard
uh for years and years and years uh
there's one side of the argument that
says hey 6040 is still
kind of the default and maybe you need
some customization from there but that's
still a pretty strong
um you know kind of framework to use uh
there's other people who say
you know are you crazy 40 of the
portfolio and bonds that are
uh you know negative on a real basis um
you have to uh completely move away from
that
and 60 40 is dead there might not be
kind of a one-size-fits-all answer here
but just how do you think about
that debate and the multiple
perspectives uh in light of
uh the customers and clients that you
have today
yeah we have to evaluate uh based on the
individual client circumstances and
goldman sachs announced earlier this
week
that they think u.s treasury is going to
be negative for the next three years
um negative returns so you have to ask
yourself gee
do i really want to own bonds in this
kind of environment well it's a silly
question because if you don't own bonds
then where's the money it's either
literally in cash earning zero point
nothing or it's in something else it's
in stocks where we know the risks
associated with that
and we know that this is fueling some of
the markets increases in 2020 the lack
of options
you know you can buy stocks and earn a
two or three or four or five percent
dividend
as opposed to putting money in a bank cd
we earn you know zero point nothing so
it's partly a lack of options for
investors and it's partly recognizing
that
we're not about to see a dramatic
increase in interest rates anytime soon
the fed says they're going to keep rates
this low for the next three years
so it's a conundrum the only way to
answer it
i believe is on a client-by-client basis
there is no one-size-fits-all i don't
think in edelman financial engines that
it is a 60 40 typical exposure i think
we're probably closer to 65 35
on average um but it's i don't think
it's it's sort of like you know how many
babies is in the average household i
think the average number of children is
2.3
but nobody has 2.3 children all right
it's so the averages are one thing but
the reality is something different so
while we talk about 60 40 or 65 35
that's all just fun conversation for you
and me the fact is
what is right for the client
specifically and for the portion that
will be in bonds because yes you do need
to have a bond exposure
the key is what are those bonds are they
long-term
intermediate or short-term are they high
quality or high yield
are they corporate or government are
they us or foreign
that's really the key issue is what is
the asset allocation within the bond
portfolio
and how can you manage that portfolio
through an effective rebalancing
strategy
that allows the portfolio to not only
complement the stock side
but to enhance the returns and reduce
the risks along the way
so i don't think it's a question of in
or out yes or no
i think it's a question of how do you
construct a sophisticated diversified
asset allocation model how do you manage
it effectively between rebalancing and
dollar cost averaging
in line with a client's goals attitudes
about risk need for liquidity and so
it is on it is very obvious you've been
doing this for a very long time because
uh the devil is in the details um
and the nuance i think in terms of uh 60
40
should i have bond should i have not um
is one question
but uh as you laid out kind of the
different ways you can just cut
the asset allocation to bonds uh can
drastically change that answer
um is that also true in terms of
nuance um when you look at bitcoin and
kind of crypto industry in terms of
whether it's different vehicles
different types of assets
um or do you think that right now people
are making a very binary
should i get exposure should i not and
we're not yet at the point where people
understand the nuance well enough to
start
making you know hey should i get uh
exposure to
the grayscale gbtc product uh
publicly traded here's the pros and cons
versus let's say the bitwise
uh you know kind of top 10 index type
structure
how do you see that conversation playing
out at the moment
it's it's a weird one uh it's a weird
conversation for two reasons one
it is largely all about bitcoin and if
you want we can toss in ethereum
and the reason is that bitcoin has 75
80 of the market you know if we look at
there are 5 000
coins out there a lot of them are fraud
a lot of them are fad
most are going to fail disappear go away
a thousand of them already have
um so out of this huge array
there's bitcoin with a 75-80 percent
market share
ethereum has another 10 or 15 percent so
between
those two you're pushing ninety percent
of all the money in digital assets in
those two coins
and i'm even going to bother going into
why those two are so big or why those
two
are the dominant and what makes the two
of them different why do you need both
it's not coke and pepsi by the way
they are radically different so you
could just simply
buy bitcoin call it a day if you want
diversification you could use the
bitwise
top 10 crypto index which gives you the
10 biggest coins cap weighted
but again bitcoin and ethereum are 70 80
they're you know
85 90 of the index the other eight coins
are tiny compared to those two so you
could do that if you wanted
and then the question becomes how do you
buy bitcoin do you go buy bitcoin
directly from an exchange you know
somebody like
coinbase or gemini or kraken uh or do
you buy bitcoin via
uh a security like gbtc um or do you buy
it from a private fund like at sky
bridge capital
or a galaxy or do you do a more exotic
trading strategy with multicoin
or some of the other funds that are
doing long short they're doing
active market timing and trading that's
where you get into
the details i think for most ordinary
mere mortals who are just getting into
this for the very first time
just a flat investment into bitcoin
simple plain
easy via via a security a private
placement a fund
offered by a vc or hedge fund or
directly to custodian is sufficient
they're all birds of a feather they're
all going to pretty much move
similarly in results
accepting for fees and the timing of
when you bought and sold but
it's it's the rising tide lifting all
boats and a tidal wave flooding them all
so i don't really think at the end of
the day it's gonna matter a hell of a
lot
it's really interesting to kind of hear
that perspective because i think that
you're directly correct for sure
of uh you know just getting exposure is
probably the most important thing is
kind of like in a portfolio the asset
allocation may be more important than
the security selection
uh you know or likely is same thing here
of just actually allocating something to
the space
um you know absolutely
um the last thing i want to talk about
is there's a lot of financial advisors
who
listen to this podcast they want to
learn about bitcoin and cryptocurrency
um and you have this certificate course
uh
really targeted right at the financial
advisors and helping them get educated
so maybe take just two minutes and
help explain a little bit about this
course that you've created
and kind of why financial advisors could
benefit from actually
attending i think it's a fantastic idea
but just tell us a little bit more about
it
we're very excited about it it debuts in
q1
we're expecting it to launch around
march 1st
we have hundreds of advisors who have
enrolled so far in the inaugural class
it's a 10 module certification program
it's an online self-study at your own
pace
program 10 modules an hour each there
will be ce credits for the course
it's 4.99 to enroll with each module
there's a quiz
and when you are finished with all 10
you are awarded the certificate if you
fail one of the modules you just retake
the quiz until you pass it's a 70
pass rate uh and the first five modules
are on
blockchain and digital assets deep dive
understanding what they are
how they work uh the impact they're
having in the financial services sector
in the uh global currency marketplace
etc
the second half of the modules are all
about practice management understanding
the
taxation and regulation understanding uh
how you include them in your practice
management how you deal with
record keeping tax reporting rebalancing
uh the different products that exist in
the marketplace and the differences
between them and understanding
how to communicate this with clients and
and how to incorporate it into your
practice
so by the time you go through these 10
modules which you could cram into a
weekend if you felt like it or spread it
out over several months as your choice
you will have the working knowledge you
need to be able to talk intelligently
with your clients
answer their questions and determine
most importantly whether or not this is
for your clients or not
and you'll know which vendors in the
crypto community
are your favorites uh for use by your
clients
uh depending on the approach that you
and they want to take
for exposure within your portfolios so
we're very excited about the program and
you can enroll right now
at our website at riodak.com
how do you spell that just so people
know it's ria
dac the riaa digital assets count
council rheadaq.com awesome
before i let you go i always ask
everyone the same three questions
uh the first one is a little bit more
serious what is the most important book
that you've ever read
um and you've written so many great
books so maybe let's do one that you did
not write but that you've read and it's
had a of
well uh of course the bible has to be
number one the number two
is probably stereotypically uh atlas
shrugged uh i'm a
huge fan of ann rand and uh i'm a big
uh i read a lot of early american
history so there are
a huge array of books that i've read
about our founders and about the
the period of our nation from the 1650s
uh all the way up to
the uh 1820s and so it's hard to pick
any one of them
but i i do subscribe to the theory that
those who refuse
to remember their history are doomed to
repeat it
i agree for sure second question is uh
is sponsored by a company called eight
sleep
they've got this amazing sleep mattress
that i've been sleeping on and
i've been spending way more time trying
to sleep
so what is your sleep routine and kind
of how
if you've been doing this for 35 years
there's an element of sustainability
of just being able to not only grow the
business but just survive
um how has maybe your sleep schedule
changed over time right when you're on
the windowsill
starting the business it may be
different than than today but just how
do you think about sleep
and how that's evolved over the years uh
well god cursed me with needing lots of
sleep you know i
keep hearing about people who can get by
on four or five hours and i wish i could
because of the productivity you gain
from the extra three hours but i need a
solid eight hours i'm really happy with
ten
uh it's terrible i don't always get it
but i usually do
uh and um the the real focus
is that a lot of folks spend a lot of
hours in bed but they're not necessarily
sleeping or sleeping well
uh and the amount of turmoil in your
covers when you wake up in the morning
determines how
restful your sleep really was and so
what i've learned is that the best way
to get a good night's sleep
is to go to bed exhausted a lot of folks
i discover go to
sleep at a boredom um they've just been
watching tv or
reading a book or they got nothing else
to do so they'll turn off the lights
because it's that time to go to bed and
so it's hard to turn the brain off
because you're just not exhausted so uh
my attitude is to work really hard play
really hard and sleep really well
um so go to bed exhausted and that is a
pretty good indication you're going to
get a good night's sleep
yeah the three things when i started
focusing on this one
was exactly that making sure i used the
apple watch and just said hey if i close
all my rings on my apple watch that
means i did a lot of physical activity
and therefore i'm probably tired
two was uh being much more intentional
about eating and drinking and not
kind of doing things right before you go
to bed you probably shouldn't eat
cookies or anything like that
um and then the last thing was this
eight sleep mattress and they make it
cool
so basically it can uh you know really
sleep in a cold environment and i didn't
understand
how impactful that was and as a kid you
just basically think of hey just go to
sleep with whatever the temperature of
the house is
uh but i i guess in terms of getting
deeper rem sleep
uh did the cool technology really work
so it's pretty cool to see you know once
you become intentional about this
actually being exhausted
and uh and ensuring you get the sleep it
actually makes you more productive
during the day as well so it's
we've had one interruption lately we got
a dog three months ago
and uh she has been jumping on the bed
and that has been um
something we're trying to deal with so
uh but that adds to the fun
yeah i love it uh the last question i
have for you and you'll get to ask me
one to finish up
is a little bit more fun aliens are you
a believer
or a non-believer oh there's
it's it's fact uh there's no question
that there is life on other planets
i spent one of my hobbies as astronomy
uh and i've gotten to know some
some pretty smart folks uh in the field
of astronomy
uh and um jean and i collect
uh old astronomy books uh as a hobby
uh there there is no question there is
no doubt that there is life on other
planets the problem is that they are so
far away that we
do not know how or when we will ever be
able to communicate with them because of
the distances so
technology has not yet been invented uh
to be able to communicate with them
but uh to suggest that in this entire
massive universe and frankly multiverse
to suggest that we are the only ones
that exist is an incredibly arrogant
egocentric attitude that uh i don't
think
any self-respecting uh professional
astronomer
would subscribe to the notion that we're
alone i
i had somebody come on the podcast i
think it was two years ago now
and uh and he said this one sentence
that just is seared to my brain he said
every human
asks two questions at some point in
their life one is
what happens when i die and the second
is are we here alone
and for whatever reason i think that's a
great framework because
uh i think that the second question of
are we here alone
you know 10 15 years ago people probably
had a harder time believing and
kind of thinking about it now though i
tend to think that the majority of folks
say yeah it's probably true that uh
but it's also irrelevant because of the
distances so the real question about
aliens is are we being visited by aliens
are we going to be visited by aliens are
they going to take over
i think that's science fiction again
because of the incredible distances
involved i don't think people fully
understand what a light year
is because it's really hard to
comprehend the distances are so
astonishingly vast
so no i do not believe that aliens are
visiting us or ever have
and i don't think they're going to any
more than we're going to be able to
visit them at least not
in the conceivable future
yeah it makes sense to me uh you could
ask me one question to
finish up what question do you have for
me well who's the favorite person
and this is not a a self-serving
question you i'm going to
let you off the hook and say you can't
name me but who's who was the best
what was the most fun interview the best
memorable interview you ever gave
um this one is going to be a weird
answer
but uh there's a guy uh mackenzie who
came on
uh who nobody in the world knows who he
is he literally dm'd me on twitter
uh as have a bunch of people and they
said hey i'd love to come on the podcast
i'm just a regular guy
um and uh if you're ever looking for
somebody who's just a regular guy to
kind of tell their story
um i would uh be more willing to do it
for whatever reason i've ignored you
know literally
50 plus people who have said that and
when this guy dm'd me
i just said yep it's time to finally do
kind of a
a normal person um if you will and so i
brought him on
and uh he does uh flooring in canada for
a living and literally kind of
you know in his town he's the flooring
guy and um
it was one cool just kind of hear his
story with bitcoin and digital assets
and kind of how he learned about them
and
why he was intrigued but he said a
single line
that i think really summed up uh most
people who listen to this podcast
actually in fact probably most of your
clients as well
which was he said look i'm not trying to
take over the world i'm just simply
trying to
provide a better life for my kids right
and and it just hit me over the head he
said you know
i have the pleasure as i'm sure you do
as well of talking to so many ambitious
successful
you know wealthy powerful influential
people that you forget like
that's actually the outlier right as
people have that aspiration
most people they say look i don't need
to take over the world i just want a a
happy life and a better life for my
family and so i think that
in some you know kind of crazy world uh
the guy who was
the one least expected to uh to have the
best information or kind of the best
advice
uh it just really hit home so i'd have
to go with him you know i uh i
talk with listeners to my radio show
constantly i you know
trade emails uh with them all the time
and and
communication with our clients
frequently and and i can tell you that
the so-called man on the street you know
the the everyday american
they are the smartest people on the
planet and we learn from them
all the time so my listeners are the
ones who ought to be hosting my show
instead of me doing the talking they
ought to be so that's a great experience
that you had that's that's brilliant
yeah where can we send people
to uh to find you on the internet or
find out more about the work that you
guys are doing
um if they're interested well you can
learn about what we're doing
for financial education in the area of
digital assets at
rheadaq.com r-i-a-d-a-c
rheadek.com and if you want to learn
about the advice and services we provide
for financial planning and investment
management then go to
rickettelman.com for edelman financial
engines and that's spelled
rice gentlemen.com
i love it rick listen thank you so much
you're an absolute legend
uh just thank you so you know for really
kind of pushing
uh i think the pace of adoption and
frankly innovation
when it comes to financial advisors with
uh with bitcoin and digital assets
you're doing a fantastic job and we'll
have to do it again in the future i'll
look forward to it thanks very much